who is polo g a dope ass artist coming
out of chicago
gonna be considered one of the greatest
one there
[Music]
what's up i'm polo g
and this is the wire auto complete
interview so i hold it up like this or
what
what polo g what is polo g
real name real name is ralph
ralph lauren what was polo g
first song my first song was oda
i recorded it in the studio when i was
17 years old
you can still find it on youtube today
what
is martin and gina about polo g
martin and gina is just about two
love birds trying to get into a
relationship and a duel who was messing
up
and somebody came in to say today what
age is polo g i'm 22 22 years old i just
turned 22 in january
what polo g what
is 21 bipolar g about i don't got like a
necessary like
meaning to it isn't a wide variety of
things i was just expressing myself
what is polo g for zodiac sign
my zodiac sign i'm a capricorn i was
born in january
to i believe in astrology to an extent
over time
you know you mean different people
and they tell you about your feminine
zodiac signs and then you find
similarities in character
what is polo g's favorite color
i don't want to be that i don't got a
favorite color guy but i really don't
got a favorite color i like
i feel like right now my favorite color
got to be like uh
green though i say because that's what i
wrapped all my cars
what is polo g most popular song
the most popular song is my breakout
song
pop out it went like number 11 on the
billboard chart
i just felt like i came straight in the
game and hit the ground running
pretty big moment for me back in like
2019.
where polo g where is polo g
from from chicago from iraq real rack
baby real block baby come on man
where does polo g
get headbands what they mean by i think
they mean his clash i used to rock the
alexander mcqueen scars
i used to grab him from rodeos sax
but i really passed that phase of
rocking those feel lives
that was really just because my dress
was shorter where is polo g's
next um i got people spamming in my
comments every day
i don't know but it's coming soon
how polo g how much is polo g
capital octane my capital i chain i got
that made from
jewelers in chicago or treasures like
forty thousand dollars
and that's crazy because i don't think i
was supposed to pay that much money for
it but i was young and gullible
how tall is polo g yeah i'm about six
foot one
how much is apollo g
feature the low g feature is pretty high
that's all i can say
is polo g it's polo g left-handed no
it's polo g a new york rapper
i'm not from new york from chicago is
polo g part of otf
no i'm not part of otf but you feel me
i'll with you
it's polo g i don't hate the other side
just searching youtube and the other
side my name's gonna pop up right next
to it
it's polo g connection
is full of g canadian no i was born in
the us
united states of america does polo g
does polo g have children i don't have
children i have a child
got a son he's one years old does polo g
have siblings i got three siblings
little sister little brother big sister
i'm still a big brother though
does polo g have tattoos i'm trying to
see how many
i got though i got that one
i got a lot of tattoos does polo g have
a platinum album i got two platinums
veronica
stats two platinum albums got the third
one on the way hall of fame don't forget
that
does polo g have his own label yeah
only dreams achieved i partnered with
suny um
in colombia for my record label i got
one artist officially and i got um
my artist's left side to me
independently who polo g
who is polo g a dope ass artist coming
out of chicago
definitely hit a state a lot of
longevity gonna be considered one of the
greatest one there
who is polo g's brother pono g
brother is trench baby come on man stop
playing little church baby you fear me
off the low end my little bro go crazy
man y'all gotta
who is polo g santo i'm signed to uh
columbia records
that's the family who are polo g's
parents okay you see my mama miss
station mac
and then i got my pops that's papa tree
family i used to be literally before i
was polo g but that's another story
when i uh googled my name i'd be
expecting something like my height
net worth polo g has a net worth of 2.5
million dollars and some crazy